we are proudly supporting the men and
women of law enforcement including our
wonderful ice officers and border patrol
agencies our incredible people who
endorsed me during the campaign and they
are incredible they're doing a great job
at the border by the way we are going to
end chain migration we are going to end
the lottery system and we are going to
build the wall
we need two or three hundred miles of
that wall or else by November 2018 so
people can see it and they'll believe it
earlier today the president promising to
reform our immigration system which is
so broken build that wall
last Monday California officially became
a sanctuary state when the law took
effect preventing state and local police
from asking people about their
immigration status or from cooperating
with federal immigration enforcement
activities in most cases Fox News
contributor Tommy Lehren hit the streets
to ask residents of California what they
think of this new law watch this are you
aware that California is now a sanctuary
state for illegal immigrants of course I
know that
and how do you feel about it I think
it's great I think it's finally it's
it's been a matter of time where we need
immigrants to be protected and I think
being a sanctuary states is perfect why
are we making it difficult for them to
become legal they don't pay their taxes
if it's difficult for the illegal they
don't do what you complain about
constantly on your channel if it's not
legal so why not make it legal for them
to do it and then you'd stop complaining
you can't have it both ways if we're
going to benefit from cheap labor then
we also have to give them the benefits
of every American citizen can benefit
them being an immigrant from Mexico
myself I think that it's an incredible
opportunity to stimulate the economy by
integrating workers that it will take
certain jobs that many of the currently
employed Americans want and I think it's
a good opportunity it's all right I love
it you know I mean I got you know family
members and myself that are illegal I
mean just being free you know you're
just out here trying to do yourself did
you know that this was a sanctuary State
for illegal immigrants I did and what do
you think about that you know I think we
need to come up with an immigration bill
that will solve all the problems and
help immigrants that are here illegally
transmitted and become US citizens I
don't think they should come over here
you said illegal immigrants
yeah I don't think this is just a with
that come over here why why didn't gotta
be over here
[Music]
how do you feel about legal immigrants
that have done it the right way that
have paid a lot of money waited a lot of
time to come into this country do you
feel like it invalidates everything that
they've worked for to let illegal
immigrants receive sanctuary in
California I don't think it's fair that
you're pitting one against the other I
think that one came here fairly and one
came here in a sense unfairly in this
sense it's not such a black-and-white
thing you know both people came here to
feed their families but if the laws are
not being enforced is that also a
problem it's it's one of these
unenforceable laws I'm an immigrant and
I had to go through a process it took
three and a half years to come to
America I think everybody should go
through a process sanctuary cities have
always been around they've only become
part of this like popular conversation
because of the way that society has
attempted to villainize immigrants they
do it illegally because they either
don't have like the means to get in or
like a safer way to get in either
illegals illegal we want to be
compassionate but we also have the rule
of law Fox News contributor Tommy Lehren
joins us
Wow that's your state right it is my
state shine and what can I tell ya
thirteen and a half percent income tax
rate in the state I mean doesn't Texas
and Florida they are pretty good
infrastructure I can tell you is better
than in New York why is there that
overwhelming feeling is this just a
California thing to you well to be fair
there are a lot of Californians that are
moving to Florida and Texas and
elsewhere because of California because
of the rules and the regulations and
because of things like it being a
sanctuary state but I gotta tell ya I'm
gonna some breaking news California is
not a lost cause I promise you it's not
there are so many undercover
conservatives in this state that I spoke
to that our level-headed that don't like
the fact that it's a sanctuary state
sometimes there are others though that
are a little bit louder squeaky wheel
gets the grease a lot of times why
should they get federal tax dollars in
any way and let if they're not if
they're literally aiding and abetting
law breaking as a state
well the absolutely shouldn't but you
have to
understand a lot of Californians that
are into the whole piece love and
welcome everyone
unless you're Tommy Lehren or Fox News
and then you know they're tuned
completely changes I'll tell you those
stories later but again these people in
California they want to be welcoming of
everyone they want to bring everyone in
until you remind them that legal
immigrants had to spend a lot of money
and wait a lot of time to get in to this
country and into the state and then
their tune changed just a little bit it
was quite fascinating you know I was
really interested as I was watching this
this package you put together and I'm
interested that a lot of people knew you
knew about Fox News newer opinions that
one guy in particular on the right I
guess it looks like a black shirt to me
and and the other guy in the gray shirt
and I'm thinking did it how was their
reaction to you and the channel because
yeah they're kind of right there are a
few of us that are real conservatives
that actually speak and I don't know if
they ever met one before well I want to
be fair we did encounter a lot of really
respectful people that liked what we do
on Fox News that like what I do but it
was interesting I spent some time in
West Hollywood in China I don't know if
you're familiar with West Hollywood but
it's a very liberal area it's the as
they call it the epicenter of the
resistance and they certainly knew who I
was and there are some words that I
can't repeat on national television that
they were screaming at me they saw the
Fox News Mike they weren't thrilled that
we were there they told us to get out
and I reminded them that they're
supposed to be the loving and tolerant
left welcoming of everyone in Lester Fox
News or Tom Eulerian and then you're
supposed to get out very interesting the
way that works yeah all right great job
Tommy we really appreciate it